[Musique]
en quarts de finale et match match
revanche match revanche
voilà entre les deux joueurs il suffit
donc comme tu me disais tout à l'heure
au no du nul à laurent frayssinet
maintenant pour l'emporter donc très
important aussi de suivre le match
belle partie d'entre elles dans la
première honda hm belles parties qui lie
quand même bombay il a chuté beaucoup
technique de l'apprendre en fait signer
à la fois gestion du temps on va dire et
puis pression permanente dans la partie
mais belle partie leur ampleur qu avec
le groupe d'amis ici avec la défense
czeslaw alors défend seul avait
caractérisé par ce coup ici alors le
coup ces six bons mais voilà par le coup
c'est si ces voix là et ce trophée qui
le jeu le quoi si c'est un conte moderne
qui est employé on va rejouer bessengue
un coup de joueurs plus tard on va
pouvoir jouer livre qui a été écrit sur
ce fort sur ce coup sûr cette variante à
6 par les joueurs de montpellier après
yaya contre évolué avec glen flir ils
ont écrit un bouquin superbe uniquement
sur cette variante
à noter que c'était le thème du match
kasparov total aux feux cramique topalov
par louis saha était et puis les grands
maîtres joue la slave systématiquement
contre le pilote donc début du tournoi
contrairement à la partie présente qui
était un début du pion roi voilà donc
ces cinq était joué donc là c'est ce
qu'on appelle à cela vaut verte
c'est-à-dire que le pion dessin prend en
c4 et il fait suivre très vite qu'ils
ont des quatre ans et cinq ans et ça me
prend des papillons des cinq avaient
pris un ami d'accord les blancs les
noirs mme pillay
hélas les noirs viennent de jouer ces
cinq pour faire pression et l'essor des
noirs ont joué ces cinq pour attaquer le
centre blanc voit la belle scène qui
justifie justifie le petit coup aussi ce
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure on avait cinq
plein d'occasions pour protéger le pion
et on attaque le fou voilà le four recul
voilà voilà
et maintenant on a joué si on en a joué
b5 avec tempo alors à noter quand même
si un petit salut un petit salut à notre
mister mystère informatique julien
favarel
c'est un excellent joueur du club de
l'aspom des grands clubs aussi de
bordeaux
oui et qui tient les manettes à droite
de la scène et bien sûr sur son pc il
vérifie que tout se passe bien
voilà donc on fait un petit salut à
julien fabre elle a ici qui qui soutient
grand prix depuis l'an dernier avec
comme ça son soutien informatique sur
l'événement cavaliers 17 je pense que là
on est un peu dans la théorie tous à
tous et qu ont été jouées et rejouées
quelle est cette voix là pour contrôler
ces cinq n'y a pas de nouveauté là et
peu coûteux
il faut expliquer les idées peut-être un
peu renault donc là développement des
pièces toujours important faut
développer les pièces aux échecs
toujours on joue alors ici toujours pour
le centre le centre 6 et 4 case centrale
très important soit de contrôler le
centre ou de l'occuper parce que les
pièces sont plus importantes sont plus
actives on va dire au centre donc à une
prépondérance du centre surtout en début
de partie
en tout cas d'éviter de concéder le
centre assauts adverses et parce qu'on
se fait vite sans raison on se fait tout
fait quoi rapidement voilà c'est ça
l'idée sont aussi on laisse trop le
centre si on ne si on ne fait rien pour
le centre alors son le cube selon le
contrôle voilà donc en l'occurrence là
il ya une tentative d'occupation par les
blancs contrôle le long des 4 mai les
noirs contre attaque avec ses 5 et à
tout moment peuvent échanger en d4 la
marque le edge ou la variante avec dame
d'autres sans doute très dynamique
il ya peut-être vouloir mettre sa tour
en d1 avec un vis-à-vis ici tour dame
madame 2 avec l'idée dames 2 c'est
simple c'est de jouer ou quatre on veut
pouvoir jouer aux quatre protéger la
case aux quatre avec le fou avec
lecavalier et après peut-être peut-être
joué aux cinq aussi c'est possible donc
les noirs en du retard de développement
un petit peu ayant par ok mais c'est
encore le tour d un fou à 9,8
alors on boit on voit c'est là qu'on
voit quand même c'est très intéressant
ce match parce qu'on voit comme jouer un
joueur comme la recrue mark lui est
championne aquitaine donc deux mille
deux cents lots donc saleuses comme on
l'a dit ça le plein avec 300 400
meilleurs français à peu près donc que
dans un très bon joueur mais qui reste
un joueur amateur c'est pas son métier
c'est un très très bon joueur amateur on
voit que donc il a quand même de très
bonnes connaissances dans les ouvertures
royer qui prend pas beaucoup de temps
pour pousser ses premiers coups sait
très bien ce qu'il fait est donc la
différence face un joueur qu'on me
laurent frayssinet le tiers dans la
meilleure organisation placement des
pièces ce qui fait là qu'un joueur le
plus performant qu'un autre c'est dans
sa perception de l'organisation du
matériel sur l'échiquier
alors il ya ça on a vu dans la première
partie que il avait très bien joué à ce
niveau là aussi est quand même bien
réussi à s'en sortir mais aussi ce
manque d'expérience de jouer des parties
rapides aussi à très haut niveau donc de
la gestion du temps la gestion du stress
et puis alors qu'au maximum à jouer
contre les meilleurs régionaux
alors que laurent a joué contre les
meilleurs mondiaux c'est à dire il a
déjà était assis en face d'un homme de
topalov de shearer de shiro dan campagne
à bordeaux d'ailleurs ont bondi shirov
les eaux
et oui donc adore j'oublie le signaler
tout à l'heure à présent temps marc lehu
avec marc lui mais qui a réussi à une
partie nulle face à pete ans l'écho à 8
ans les coupes quatrième joueur mondial
alors c'est en simultané mais ça ne fait
rien c'est très souvent les joueurs qui
donnent des simultanée arrive à faire
des nuls contre des grands maîtres
prouve par là qu'ils ont un des qualités
non négligeable avec ici d'un v6 et il
renforce alors la dame ici la pression
donc la dame évident sur des quatre par
transparence ici continue la pression
sur des cadres mais surtout la dame
s'enlève du vis-à-vis de la tour parce
que tu y as des échanges est bien c'est
qu'on est toujours désagréable au
dernier moment de se retrouver avec la
tour face à la dame puisqu'il suffit que
le fou dans ce qu'elle apprenne le cube
et scène par exemple et latour attaque
la dame ce qui permet de gagner un petit
on est quand ses papilles en voilà à 4
tout de suite
laurent ici donc à fedak attaque la
chaîne de pions
installé par les noirs c'est la menace
et les simples à ses pions prendre les 5
comprend les cinq d'abord j'échange les
tours dans un premier temps et après fou
prend le pion b5 et perdu le foot rend
hommage à la dame défend et le cavalier
défend aussi en menace de gagner un pion
mais surtout on applique le principe qui
est le suivant si je suis mieux
développer j'ouvre les lignes toute
ouverture de ligne profite au camp le
mieux développé ce quart temps qu'il
essaie absolument d'ouvrir les ligues
bon et est notre ami levêque et ses 2
ouvrir le moins de lignes possibles car
son roi n'est pas encore à l'abri mais
pas encore en sécurité pour qu'il
profite du fait de l'exposition du fou
les trois pour jouer le coup c4 mais
n'en sort lancé francine il s'était à
priori c'est free style exotique donc
ici wilfrid blog têtu comment donc là la
menace était trop forte donc là
freyssinet bloque la menace en jouant c4
d'où l'intérêt pas prendre tout de suite
en d4 avec le pion sait on prend au bon
moment où alors on joue ces quatre comme
ça a été fait l'a donc là le foot doit
reculer sans doute en c2 puisque en eux
quatre ils seraient en prise à la fois
du fou bessette et du cavaliere 6 et ne
saurait défendu que par le canal et ses
trois donc il serait perdue le fou
cavaliers prendre fou car les pointes
cavaliers fou prend lé noir ont gagné
une pièce tout simplement donc le fou
n'a pas de case ont probablement le seul
coup pour les blancs assez évident
d'ailleurs ainsi joué sous ses deux
pouces et 2 et pas trop le choix
d'ailleurs poussé deux mais bon ça doit
être une partie toujours théorie
attention maintenant les mails et blanc
dont les vents joué 4 blanc la majorité
centrale mais les noirs en la majorité
mobile sur les dames voilà une majorité
si ce côté mais les noirs par ok 1 il ya
quand même la peau cité jouer eux quatre
des cinq avec ouverture des lignes
attention quand même attention on l'a
poussé deux voilà c'était un coup
quasiment évident il aurait pu jouer
plus vite marque lui avec parce que là
il perd du temps la pendule on a vu
comme c'était important la première
partie je crains ce qu'il voulait c'est
ce qu'il fallait qu'ils sachent ce
qu'ils allaient faire sur b4 alors
attention beaucoup de coups de
desperados là un petit peu
renault des cas traités jouer attaquant
le cavalier est à 5 tout de suite et
maintenant cavaliere car oui veut pas
reculer il veut pas reculer marque il
veut pas reculer en b1 et il veut jouer
son cavalier sur à 4 voilà il n'a pas
peur de dame prend pions apparemment
mais alors attention dans le côté il
veut sans doute jouer eux 4 suivi deux
des cinq pour essayer d'ouvrir le centre
profitant du roi noir au centre dame
prend 1,5
ce serait sans doute un échange
puisqu'ils auraient dame prend ses 4
alors attention là c'est sans doute un
moment crucial pour la partie pour
laurent frayssinet keller quand même
dans son élément évidemment il connaît
très bien la slovénie la joue un je
crois oui oui la joue cncd favorites
comme c'est une défense qui est très à
la mode est très étudié attention les
noirs peuvent prendre le pli snk et je
sais que mes il perdrait le pion ses
cannes voilà c'est ça je suis pas étonné
que le roi apprécier les joues cette
variante puisqu'il a énormément de
travailler avec eric priet qu'est ce que
c'est que ce qu'on mérite prix y est un
bébé d'à france et 4 à l'air assez fort
quand même
ça paraît bizarre quand même des changes
est le plus ancien une contribution ses
4000 habitants est pas le choix
d'ailleurs laurent frayssinet
il connaît très bien son affaire 1 marc
lui est quand même un en termes
d'ouverture il connaît très bien son
affaire il sait exactement ce qu'il fait
c'est sûr dame prince et cathya aura
peut-être fou prime 3 quand même qui va
à wipro fournit fou prendre cavaliers en
m'obligeant de reprendre avec le pion et
la cassant la casse et la défense du
real et force du roi mais il ya dans
cette affaire de fous est dans une
position là du retard de développement
oui donc ce biais que les noirs on vit
très vite de jouer food et 6 ou fawcett
est de faire le petit robe très très
vite parce que là ça commence à être
pénible d'avant le roi au centre il ya
quand même une dame
ici on vis-à-vis pour l'instant et
pourtant si on va en effet la belge
voilà il fait d'avoir en c4 est
d'ailleurs il a pris un sac voilà alors
maintenant on attend sans doute
qu'est ce qu'on attend des noirs ici
avait peut-être fou prend un cavalier
évident peut-être peut-être fou dessin
classique et un coût qui est un coup
intéressant food et 5 intermédiaire me
pour peut-être
fort cb31 pour jouer les 3 pourquoi pas
oui parce qu'on risque de d'embêter les
pièces blanches mais parce que là le
problème ce cavalier là il est quand
même là tout cavalier la carélie ouais
hein donc s'il ne peut pas jouer b3
leblanc s'il peut jouer b3 il a plus de
souci si le blanc défend son cavalier
avec b3 mais s'il subit b3 il aura
toujours le clouage silva
si les noirs font b3 il peut y avoir des
problèmes après il ce cavalier par
exemple cavale et b6 et ou bâle cavani
mais bon le problème de foule et 5 c'est
que ce fou sera exposée à la poussée de
4 alors sur fou ici on a trop l'autre
voilà oui certes on enlèverait la dame
par exemple on b2 et hop
4on en oeuvre est la dernière et 2 et en
pousserez ou ans le 2 4 et en menace 4
suite des 5
parce que si on la mer nettement par
exemple les premières et il semblerait
quand même que moi j'aime bien la
position des blancs là encore au nom
donc les blancs on au quai en leur seul
sait ce blu âge cette horreur et le fou
noir qui est vraiment le fou le case
noirs des blancs qui est vraiment
mauvais attention moi j'ai quand même
j'ai peur pour les blancs rhône ont
quand même aussi de sa poursuite wiltord
s'est vite s'ils attaquent la dame et
derrière il ya le fou ces deux il peut
très bien y avoir
qu'est ce qui se passe sur tours c8
wintour s'est vite c'est quand même
embêtant entourent s'est vite force
d'âme à deux voies la dame par le 2e
tour alors dame h5 le coup totalement
inattendu menace de gagner menace fou
prend f3 puis on prend et d'un premier
front avec un endroit complètement à
l'ouest comme on dit c'est qu'elle
l'audience aussi des quatre coups que
l'on là c'est plutôt l'esstin en fait
l'ouest serait plutôt à gauche sur
l'échiquier
mais israël sur les cartes de géographie
l'ouest et à gauche voilà donc quand tu
es bien aux échelles pour son
naproxcinod géographie et chaque fois
tout donc damage 5
alors c'est des coups surprenante
toujours les grands coups latéraux de
dames comme ça ils s'en surprennent a
toujours les attention aussi à des idées
comme joueur des six joueurs qu'il a
subie food et 6 renault j'ai peur aussi
pour marc l'alleud avec food et 6 validé
foulée 6 va forcer les attaques et h2 va
forcer les blancs les affaiblissements
j'ai trop défend et puis comment on
défend à 2 sur eb66 le coup cavaliers g4
arrivera
le fou le fourbe et 7 est très puissant
est-ce que les pompes a intérêt à jouer
un coup comme je te demande car alice et
5 pour menacer le faux bessette tout de
suite
sept cavaliers c5 et un cookie perham
payant quand ma mère ça sert sa
péremption mais sur wii s'habille sûr
mais mais mais peut-être qu'il ya quand
même la vence de développement parce que
l'idée renault sur calais csn c'est pour
jouer 3 4 pour clouer 17
ça peut jouer aussi ça pourrait être une
idée
il y aura sans doute on peut regarder
dépend on va regarder cette barre
antiroulis dit voilà on sait que la dame
ici donc de laurent frayssinet peut
attaquer h-2a l'attaquent aussi f3 en
liaison avec le fou qui tape sur f3 et
avec l'idée food et six aux menaces
franck cavallier suivi de dame prend h2c
presque maths et puis c'est presque
matelas avec le flou qui protège le pion
h 2 voilà donc il revient c'est pour ça
qu'il revient d'un voyage de dfa pour
déjà pour défendre la menace primaire à
qui est un rêve 3 donc il n'a pas vu où
il a pas pensé au cou qui avait laissé
cinq qui a attaqué le fou c'est qu'ils
pouvaient menacer x 4 avec un précieux
succès sur 17 hockey le fou prenait sans
doute en f3 et puis après d'armes près
neuf mois il avait nulle avec d'argent
quatre dames f3 il faut pas oublier
qu'il ne peut pas accepter la nulle
peut-être avec les échecs c'est vrai
habituel doit gagner c'est comme la
partie de la première du premier quart
de finale où devait gagner johan benita
et donc il n'avait pas le choix alors la
foulée 6 face à bout de force et d
affaiblissement cavaliers maui pour
empêcher aux quatre évidemment sur food
et 6
on aurait joué le quart 4 l pour
intercepter le fou voilà le ku'damm de
préparer le 4 voilà on peut 4 pour à la
fois prendre le centre est intercepté le
fourbe et c'est donc le rafraîchit des
blocs l'avancé ces précisions
oui bien sûr et très précis il fallait
jamais cavalier 1,4 et n'ont pas foulé
si ce temps la suite donc la foulée
c'est ton contrôle en fait très
positionnelle ce que vient de faire
laurent frayssinet il prend son temps et
il veut terminer son développement leur
fait signer par food et 6 ce coût d'un
machin qui est très fort en fait
finalement traite en fait quelque part
les pièces mineurs blanche sens moins
bien organisés que les pièces mineurs
noir il ya un problème que pour le fouet
fuite et même pas le fou et fit votre
sortie en hausse et un fou de savoir
qu'un fou sur sa case de départ est déjà
développé pourvu que la diagonale soit
ouverte
il prétend l'avoir être d'un autre côté
les chiliens de coûts
donc attention le foot est roi la food &
3 ces colis des fous des trois ans c'est
très bizarre ce coup là un fou des trois
c'est quoi l'idée un os non je vois pas
d'idée d'ailleurs milliers tous les
trois c'est peut-être de faire pression
sur a6 après des six mois là tout de
suite voilà on le voit tout de suite la
menace pèse maintenant sur le pillage de
leurs pour l'instant le khalife 3 tient
mais will imaginer que des ce cavalier
bouge
le fou pour apprendre le cavalier et
ensuite le pillage de boom dame prend
h2c presque maths à la mena donc la
menace ici et cavaliers g5
alors on pourrait jouer cavalier g5
ouais on peut jouer que c'est une vraie
menace
émanation calais g5 parce que si
regardez vous allez voir une combinaison
de matériels français y joue à 3 voilà
il était obligé parce que sur cavani
j'ai cinq ans manas y avait à l'épreuve
trois ans comme menacée car les princes
3 aidé par le fou et la dame donc
c'était quasiment et puis d'un proche
d'eux et sur cavale et prend cavaliers
il y avait d'un proche de soutenu par le
fou des six ici d'un prend le roi devait
bouger en f1 et ensuite j'avais maths en
h1 le roi ici était bloquée pouvait pas
sortir
oui donc là ça y ait transfert des des
forces
vous avez vu le flou des leurs qui
dormait en fuite s'est activée sur la
diagonale ouverte les deux diagonales
castro a été nécessaire et de dia
blanche et noire la vise le rôle petit
rock
le roi s'est mis en sécurité les tours
sans lier ça y est le développement
noire est finie les pièces sont actives
de fouet n'ont rien de fou énorme et les
pièces blanches sont plutôt pas assez
coordonnés ce cavalier à 4 se foutent
c'est alors regardez ouais voilà on va
on va noter que son palier en bloquant
olala ou j'aime pas ce que ça sent la
combine donc là il va sans doute y avoir
un petit relais tranquille les cavaliers
à des tensions au sein du sdf 6 mai il
ya la dame en l'air admettant leur dame
était en l'air dont attention la dame
est en l'air lui falloir sortir la dame
donc le coup là ici de marque c'est pour
simplifier parce qu'il semble que la
pression est terrible d'ailleurs
peut-être que l'europe de au freycinet
était un peu qu'il faut jouer il faut
jouer d'alger 6 un peu trop rapide la
pjj et si sale air forcé d'agir
oui effectivement la musique et en
charge et d'ablaye doit réfléchir à
savoir si les charges les dames
non je pense qu'il va changer d'âme
parce que danger si ce n'est pas pas
l'air très bon à cause de f3 tout
simplement si les changes les dames f3
et cesser la finale difficile qui arrive
est peut-être al'avantage des des blancs
parce que ils ont cette belle majorité
centrale et le pion à six vastes
arriérés qui on va dire que ce pion va
on en est pas là on a des polars il peut
encore jouer
il fait de me prendre bon il change les
dames comprends mais bon pour l'instant
ils tiennent à qu'asuka donc le fou
savoir ce que je voulais dire talent
j'ai pas eu le temps
l'intérêt d'avoir bloqué la case au cap
pour laurent frayssinet outre les
combinaisons qu'on a vu qu'ils étaient
possibles c'est d'avoir bloqué les pions
ici sur noir et se fout et se fout c'est
un il est bloqué et tant qu'il est
bloqué mais ces deux tours on ne peut
pas sortir et on ne peut pas jouer b3
élite à cause de laquelle ces trois si
on joue ça pour jouer foulée 2 abyss
affaibli cette quasi lecavalier s'est
alors ces trois cas valéry bernier à la
paire de flou puisque l'on peut pas
laisser gratuitement c'est toi la paire
de fous tu vois tu vas trop vitraux non
tu vas trop vite qu'est ce que c'est que
la peur de la paire de faim
et c'est avoir de fous pas mal son
adversaire nana coeur donc ça c'est une
paire de fou oui père de fou contre deux
cavaliers ou contrefout et cavaliers
voilà tant que les adversaires aussi les
deux fous on parle pas de père de fou
voilà parce que c'est neutraliser mais
si on a deux fous et les adversaires n'a
pas là l'équivalent on considère souvent
que les fous sont légèrement supérieures
cavale et surtout quand on a deux fous
parce qu'on peut contrôler à distance et
des pièces quand même à l'emporter là à
la fois les cases blanches et les quinze
mois mais surtout lorsque la position
est ouverte bien évidemment si la
position est ferme et les fous perdent
énormément de leur valeur c'est à dire
s'il ya des pions bloqué à lancer sur
l'échiquier c'est une position qui est
plutôt or là la position est plutôt en
faveur de toute paire de fou qui restera
vivante puisqu'il n'ya pas de pire
bloquer les pieds en sang mobiles toutes
les structures de fiances en ville alors
regardez comme marc lemay il joue très
très bien aussi positionnement ils
viennent jouer au foot et trois
attaquants lecavalier au 4 et voilà ils
ont apprécié n'hésite pas alors ça c'est
un affaiblissement positionnelle mais il
n'hésite pas parce qu'il veut tuer se
fout en fait ils jouent contre ce fou
laurent fasciné donc il veut contrôler
toujours là dans la veille avoir les
échanges et là il va reprendre les pieds
en chef du pion du fonds non il va
reprendre du pied en chef pour pouvoir
travailler sur la colonne f
il veut travailler sur cette colonne je
peux par exemple doubler détour par
exemple tous rêvent cette toile fuite et
attaquer les cherche d'abord le fou à
l'échangé faut d'abord voilà donc
c'était la question que je me posais
essayer d'aller sans problème à lui
c'est que là nul lui suffit donc il a
mis les pièces faut pas oublier ça là
nul suffit à laurent fasciné pour se
qualifier donc en changeant les fous le
pion f va reprendre au niveau du temps
la marque lui est que maintient la
cadence pour l'instant neuf minutes
contre 10 minutes contre deux pour
laurent frayssinet donc l'autriche n'a
pas l'heur de forces est trop dans ce
match pour l'instant
et ensuite il va tranquillement doublé
sur ou sous la colonne c'est peut-être
un aussi qu'il va jouer sur la colonne
c'est les blancs un problème il va
falloir jouer dont il refuse et refusent
ils attaquent le cas les 17 et refuse
d'échangés le fou de cases blanches
intéressant
très intéressant ce qu'il vient de faire
marque aussi parce qu'il va peut-être
pouvoir plus tard recycler son cavalier
par b6 et c 4 attention cavaliers qui
pour l'instant est à la bande
attention à cavalier mais si c'est parce
qu'il y aurait tomber oui et oui mais
surtout v8 y aurait et kamal et ses
cavaliers c4 pourquoi pas donc il
faudrait d'abord alors il démarre il
chasse le fou d'abord joli coup
classique aussi un jeu profite du pion
g2 ici pour créer une mini chaîne de
pions qui contrôle la case 4 voilà je
commence à contrôler des quatre
centrales et je fais fuir ce fou qui est
quand même un peu pénible ce qui
contrôle quand même des cases et dans
l'est dans le camp adverse a poussé deux
tours c'est un il fallait choisir une
case pour la tour il a joué très vite
évidemment tours 2-1 parce que
maintenant il a joué au quatrime joué 4
il va se servir d'eux mais il peut pas
jouer au théâtre toujours il y avait
quelques cavaliers le pion le fou ça
fait beaucoup aimé le point le prêt par
jour il prend peut-être les jouets
sicile s'il joue au fond des deux puits
torcéen ainsi il peut il peut il peut le
jouer au nom parce que jouer le 4 par
exemple si on prend et il peut jouer
tous ces six oui et puis là où avec une
fourchette fouet il a aussi 24 pions il
a aussi poussé quatre qui le fou ici
pour attaquer le pian et 6 pour attaquer
ce pion ici faible avec un clouage un
trait boukhlouf pion un pion héros un
l'idée l'idée peut-être de jouer b3 pour
que le fou le case blanche des blancs
soit enfermé c'est vrai que si c'est
tout simplement pas d'eux qu'ils
gagneraient se fout si j'étais faiblesse
il peut jouer poussé 4 amélie des baies
3 et 3 2 avec l'idée des trois tours à
deux tours à deux attaques le fouet si
refoulé est tombé de qui gagnerait le
fou qui n'a pas de case pour ce sous
trois mois la foulée donc il veut éviter
ça bien évidemment il joue fougue et 3
on ne veut pas s'en fout soit voilà il
aurait nié est là pour empêcher tous ses
cadres hays et donc il protège sa
défense sa faible assise pour telle
faiblesse mais mais mais il n'empêche
pas eu quatre renault y perd 2,4 à voile
a eu le fait tout de suite marqué avec
attention la menace fourchette
faites attention aux cinq fourchette
entre le fou et le cavalier gagnerie une
pièce donc il faut absolument que
laurent frayssinet empêche cette menace
évidente à y joue très très bien marque
le but est de la graine joué et marqué à
la très jolie partie fou g35 attaque la
tour 3 très bonne partie d'ailleurs les
joueurs qu'ils comprennent bien et où
voilà s'organise toujours pour trouver
la tour on va voir une souplesse dans le
jeu des pions avec tout le temps des
lieux au possible sur les filles gagnent
duo ses deux clients qui sont côte à
côte alors attention il y aurait ou là
là je vois une combinaison un peu
compliqué mais on imagine autour d'eux
food est un atout revient en d2 pour
attaquer le fou et maintenant je prends
le cavalier
bon il a pas fait je prends cavaliers
après tout reprend je fais tour c8 et le
fou n'a plus de cases
bon ça marche et peut-être pas j'ai vu
ça rapidement
c'est bon c'est un peu compliqué on va
revenir à des choses simples
donc on va revenir un aulas est revenu
en c2 laurent fasciné il aulas il le
travail le travail au corps c'est
terrible menace de gagner il menacé
pyongyang
il est revenu en c2 les menaces de
gagner le prix henri iv c'est terrible
le va et vient qui fait dire on prend et
on prend le cavalier prendre défendant
le fou j'ai trois temps la menace la
menace évidemment ses pions prend 1,4
alors un fût ses cadres il contre
attaque sur leur prestation aussi sur la
petite cécile le très bien joué ici très
bien joué alors là est ce que laurent
voulzy n'a pas tout simple voilà il
prend 1,4 seul c'est pas grave de père
aussi s'il jouera suite est en fait ce
qui est important c'est qu'il a éliminé
e 4 son attention sur la prise le foot
attaqué je la reprends du cavalier
phobique là nul suffit à laurent
frayssinet évidemment qui peut être
l'affairé de cette position c'est qu'il
ya toujours le retard développement sur
les dames la tour est toujours un le fou
est toujours en c1 et qu' il a détruit
le centre depuis il va reprendre du
cavalier non non ils vont plus fou fou
et 4 totalement réinventé des cavaliers
en plus tu as détruit le lay il protège
les très importants ils protègent le fou
et ensuite le mais il pouvait pas jouer
il faut être deux
non parce qu'ils pourquoi on ne pouvait
pas parce que lecavalier a pris qu'est
la tour ne protégez pas parce que tant
que le cavalier tu es là voilà donc
lille a pris d'abord alors maintenant
fou et deux échecs où va le roi et en
encaisse le fjord et 4 quand même les
voilà il prend le tour n'est qu'après
les noirs sont beaucoup mieux oui ça y
est y avions de plus inquiétant il ya un
pion de plus il ya un retard de
développement des pièces bien placé au
centre de cavaliers cas très fort ça va
être très dur maintenant pour voir que
le mec
alors attention puisque si le plombier
de tombes y aura deux pions passé lié ce
qui est terrible depuis on passe est lié
scipion b2 tombe ce qui est très
probable par exemple siffle fou bouge
alors regardant les pièces et d'ailleurs
il va où il a pas de casse ou les pièces
noires sont tout tactile et quatre
pièces camara sans doute ainsi très fort
utile
c'est très fort la menace en plus des
noirs menaçants sans doute de prendre en
f3 c'est très très fort les noirs sont
beaucoup mieux alors il faut rappeler
pour à la fois f5 voilà très intéressant
c'est ce qui est intéressant à jouer de
la part là encore une fois de marque lui
est très intéressant ce coup franc aux
l'idée c'est que si cavale et bouge
évidemment il ya derrière le fou ces
deux le coup laurent fasciné tour des
huit
oui c'est pour ne pourra empêcher tout
reste quatre tours f4 qui ont attaqué
tôt 24 attaques le jass à oui peut-être
c'est très bizarre le coup de laurent
frayssinet la tour des huit
il va jouer fou 1 5 échecs quoi ils
menacent fouet cinq échecs puis tour d
un influent cinq échecs ou valeureux 1
évidemment si le roi des sens il ya tour
d 1 ha la la il a pas vu que c'est ce
que coûtera 2 charge des pièces un an
mais c'est une erreur à oui biensur on
là c'est foutu s'est perdue là ça y est
fauché trois là c'est pas là c'est
terrible
dans la série peu c'est fini alors ce
qui ce qui peut prendre il peut faire
qu'à l'étranger trois regarde la chose
il le fait et voilà il corriere regardez
regardez c'est horrible c'est horrible
ce qui se passe puisque ici si la tour
prend le fou est perdu le fonds est
perdu et le fou ici continue à
immobiliser la tour qui est cloué voilà
c'est terminé mais il a ses failles
voilà donc ce que je voulais dire c'est
là vraiment j'adore le joueur
plus fort organise ses 1000 s est alors
que ce dernier regarde que ça arrive sur
l'échiquier il a déjà ses pièces sur les
bords du lien distendu m d'intervenir
mais voilà belles parties de frayssinet
[Musique]
voilà fin de ce match une victoire nette
de laurent frayssinet part de zéro donc
là peut-être
[Musique]
juste un petit mot marque sur la pulsion
final on tu as dû abandonner c'était m
puisse le voir c'était c'était s'était
perdue il y avait plus rien à espérer
je pense que
mais avec le roi et
il y avait des menaces immédiates je
parlais de ma période
de plus suivant java
pour moi c'était plus la peine le menu
petit range était moins bien d'autres
motifs pour pékin alors peut-être avoir
un petit monde aura aussi sans faute est
cette deuxième partie la première était
difficile les deux parties étaient assez
tendues et même je crois que chaque
moment dans la première manche j'étais
toujours un petit peu mieux moi c'était
nul simplement du temps et dans la
deuxième
je pense que j'étais un peu moins bien
en fait parce que je suis un peu trop
s'est passée ta contre compris c'est ce
que j'ai fait dans le film peut-être un
peu moins bien mais bon ça va du nord de
bonnes chances de tenir et après ils
vont évidemment il s'est un peu
embrouillé doit sortir cette pièce est
bon je pense que c'était une partie
il partit pas clair tout simplement car
si on peut les applaudir encore voilà
pour ce match au deuxième quart de
finale de ce grand prix voilà merci et b
pour ceux qui y restent donc à 20h donc
démarrera le troisième quart de finale
de ce grand prix entre hicham hamdouchi
et le champion d'europe cadets le maître
international roumain edward 16 ans
champion de france et champion d'europe
talent est donc la grande peut-être la
grande surprise de ce
[Musique]